merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur philippe meunier merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
défense qui n'est pas là j'attends avec
délectation la réponse de monsieur le
guen monsieur le ministre en accord avec
françois hollande vous avez fait le
choix d'acheter à l'étranger le
remplaçant du famas fusils d'assaut et
qui pendent nos armées françaises aucune
des grandes nations de ce monde n'a fait
un tel choix d' abandon de souveraineté
pour ce type d'armement aucune nous vous
mettons au défi de prouver le contraire
votre décision d'acheter à l'étranger le
remplace du famas finalistes de surcroît
le démantèlement et la mise à mort d'une
filière industrielle française elle est
d'autant plus injustifiée et
incompréhensible que des entreprises
françaises sont tout à fait capables de
produire un fusil d'assaut de qualité et
compétitifs contrairement à vos
allégations mais vous avez préféré
emprunter le chemin de la facilité celui
de la désindustrialisation initiée par
lionel jospin qui avait décidé
d'abandonner toute production de
munitions de petit calibre en france
avec des conséquences désastreuses connu
de tous tout ceux qui travaillent
sérieusement sur ce dossier savent
pourtant depuis longtemps que nous
pouvons produire sur le sol national ses
armes et ses munitions en temps
faudrait-il avoir la volonté et le
soutien d'un gouvernement digne de ce
nom pour défendre les intérêts
industriels de la nation ce n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui
ces tâches à l'étranger de notre futur
plu d'assaut vient malheureusement
s'ajouter à la loi macron de juillet
2015 autorisant la fusion de nexter et
de l'entreprise allemande kfw qui aura
pour conséquence de mettre fin à toute
production de chars lourds en france si
rien n'est fait pour s'y opposer en 2010
est le successeur du char leclerc comme
le successeur du famas sera à lui aussi
allemand monsieur le ministre les
dirigeants les ingénieurs et les
ouvriers de l'armement terrestre du
petit calibre et du chars lourds mérite
autant de respect et de considération
que ceux travaillant dans les filières
aéronautiques et navales qui connaissent
le succès dans un marché mondial de
l'armement forte expansion pourquoi
refusez vous de faire confiance à leurs
compétences pourquoi les siens
l'industrie étrangères la production de
césaire c'est de l'inventer réponse aux
bridgeurs et de nos emplois
n secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le première si monsieur le
président monsieur le député vous aviez
bien anticiper car vous savez que jean
yves le drian est aujourd'hui retenu
dans une réunion importante où justement
je crois qu'il le travail sur les sujets
que vous vouliez aborder la deuxième
remarque que je voulais faire vous avez
raison de parler de cette question du
fameux famas qui a eu le droit pas
d'ailleurs à une notice biographique
dans le monde la semaine dernière qui
était très évocatrice pour les uns et
pour les autres nous devons faire en
sorte de remplacer plus de cent mille
armes de poing de petit calibre à vous
le soulignez monsieur le député pour la
période 2014 2019 il y a eu la volonté
du gouvernement d'ouvrir un appel
d'offres et oui il était possible de que
cet appel d'offres soit ouvert à
l'ensemble les entreprises mais depuis
la manifestion depuis la manufacture
d'armes de saint-etienne qui a été fermé
dans les années 90 nous ne possédons
plus sur le territoire national
d'industrie pérenne solide capable de
produire cette arme néanmoins et c'est
pourquoi une entreprise allemande a été
retenu c'est pourquoi aussi nous avons
fait en sorte que cette entreprise
allemande travaille avec des entreprises
françaises en matière de fourniture
complémentaires sur ce fusil et bien
évidemment vous le savez puisque vous
connaissez ces questions se fusiller
déjà en service dans les armées
françaises notamment dans les troupes
spéciales et il donne satisfaction pour
le reste j'ai cru comprendre dans vos
questions mais je vous renvoie à ce
moment là à la philosophie politique et
économique de votre propre sensibilité
que vous vous imaginiez qu'il était
absolument impossible de travailler au
plan européen avec d'autres industries
ce n'est pas notre vision des choses
nous pensons qu airbus ça a donné un
certain nombre de résultats et nous
pensons que nexter c'est la solution
pour la filière française aussi en
matière d'armes